having that experience like we had with Justice
League the first time around where you're like
this movie is making a lot of money and it's
still tanky like I don't want I'm so nervous
to see this like make a billion point five and
people go man Avatar really underperformed yes
I am shamelessly plugged out today ladies and
gentlemen how you guys doing we are here today
to talk about how avatar The Way of the water I
think they should have had two does there that's
just my personal opinion the Avatar The Way
of the water the might actually underperform
at the box office because the expectations are
through the roof so I wanted to go over quite a
few things because I think this is like a really
interesting upheaval battle that the movie might
actually have to endure I didn't think it would
be in this position but hearing some reports that
have been coming out I'm pretty surprised by what
we're hearing so guys if you can leave a like for
John for John being here please like John Johnny
can I stop now like button so guys go for it the
main thing that's been taken off is the fact that
James Cameron has been coming out and saying that
this movie needs to make like two billion dollars
to just break even that's not a preface that's
just for the studio to go this was worth the time
money that is insane to me like wow how much did
this movie cost because the early reporting for
the budget was like 250 million dollars and I'm
like what you need to make two billion dollars
it needs to become the third or fourth highest
grossing film in order to burn I'm just like that
it's just nutty to me there's other things I want
to go over like streaming and other things
and why I think it has a chance of doing it
for sure it's just nuts to me but it's also the
most unique position I think any filmmaker has
ever found themselves in when it comes to the
sheer volume of business they have to gen like
as much as James Cameron is an innovator and a
pro I would be sweating constantly I mean yeah
because they need to turn a profit especially if
you want to make 14 more Avatar sequels you need
to make it you need to make a buck here man he
was out here saying if Avatar 2 doesn't perform
you know that I guess I'll just have to wrap it
all up in part three and I'm like if this doesn't
perform I don't know if there will be a studio
left to funny three it's just like the dialogue
that he's like giving in these interviews I'm like
you don't sound the most optimistic sometimes the
way you're talking about how you think Avatar
the way of water might do because right now we
have early projections estimated and usually
you know Studios try to be a little bit modest
um in the beginning so you know under promise
over deliver is usually a great way sometimes
they start minimizing that The Closer they get to
the release date but yeah the early projections
right now are between 150 to 170 million dollars
which is good yeah it's not like one of the some
of these Marvel movies that have like an early
projection they can be a little bit higher still
if you mind two billion dollars now there's some
good things here that that can get them to there
all right like I was looking through some numbers
and they don't really have any competition for a
while all right that's a great thing Avatar makes
for a great holiday experience the first one came
out around the holidays and did well and had
a really great run also it's getting a release
in China which should definitely help you have
a good boost the trailer for Avatar the way of
water the first trailer had like I think 148.6
million views on it so if every one of you buys
a ticket it'll break even into that two billion
Mark I think it'll be like oh it'll be above 2
billion if every one of you buy the tickets Imax
or a 3D ticket especially it should do well and
this is one of those rare films where you say 3D
and people might be like you know what yeah let's
go see this in 3D I actually might want to do
it which will help boost ticket sales now there
are some uh things that have changed though in
the in the last 10 years one is was the amount
of trailer views that the movie was getting the
interest was that just because oh Avatar's back
but what is the overall reception to it like yeah
this does look gorgeous but are people dying to
see this in the theaters secondly to make that
money to make a profit you have to have people
who really want to do repeat viewings of it
yeah that's not movies like Spider-Man no way
home almost made two billion dollars during
the pandemic because the people kept going
back to the theaters to watch that film same thing
with Avengers end game it did great like the first
Avatar movie with its re-releases combined this
close to making three billion dollars it's like
very very very close with Avatar the way of water
like we're very excited for it I think it looks
just gorgeous it looks absolutely gorgeous it
looks like a massive technological innovation and
something that levels up significantly from the
first movie but a common thing not everyone feels
this way I'm just saying this is a common thing
that you hear about that the movie is beautiful
but the story didn't quite land as strong as a
lot of people were kind of hoping for right now
any movie that gets super popular usually hears
some type of eventually the criticism becomes a
really strong you know topic of conversation with
any movie that gets really popular yeah it's the
way it goes it's the way it goes I get it but
like with the way of water I am curious to know
like are most people feeling like wow I really
gotta see this or wow this feels different or does
it just feel like we're revisiting with just like
some water [__] going on in there you know what
I mean whereas like with some of these franchise
movies you see that they are doing something like
Spider-Man no way home for just one example like
oh they're bringing all these different characters
in here oh cool like with the way the landscape is
we love like Crossovers and all this [__] can we
get an avatar crossover going can Predator land
on Pandora can we do that but even with top gun
Maverick coming back you know there's a Nostalgia
factor of Top Gun in the trailers it is such an
amazing job showing us now this is going to be
a different kind of film experience for sure one
that we haven't quite had before yet so with this
movie is really going to need more than anything
else it's just the best goddamn Word of Mouth that
has ever existed right absolutely yeah like this
movie's gonna need insane word of mouth because
when Avatar one came out that was the thing it
was the word of mouth I had never even seen
a trailer a me trailer reaction guy had never
even seen the trailer for it and I went because
I just love James Cameron movies and I was like
yeah I gotta watch everyone keeps won't shut up
about it so I gotta check this movie out I want
because of that and a lot of people went to watch
Avatar because it was such a unique experience but
you know it's like as great as this looks that
unique Factor has definitely diminished now that
we've gotten used to the world of Pandora you know
yeah and more and more like really effects driven
films it's like you have the first avatar coming
out at a time where I think everybody grasped
the idea that like wow this is a huge technical
Innovation so we can cut the story some slack and
some people like the movie's story but a lot of
people gripe that it's you know FernGully or any
number of other things and I feel like one thing
that worries me as beautiful as these trailers
looking as much as like the time passage I
feel like is uh help because anybody who's
a bit interested in the movie business probably
can sense that there's been a lot of innovating
going on in this movie there might be enough time
to build that Nostalgia for 2009 but people are
also looking at this trailer and going first
trailer the teaser the final trailer none of
these really give a sense for what the story is
aside from something that looks a lot like what
we did the first time and that's the big thing
that worries me for this movie because we've sat
here and gone this looks so beautiful the cultural
aspects that made the first avatar really touching
are all there but what is going to separate and
make the story stand taller and brighter than
the first movie and that's the thing I think the
movie really needs to prove to everybody yeah it
needs to have that it needs to be so justified
in the fact that people will want to keep going
back because this movie is also really freaking
long it's a long ass movie I think James Cameron
I forget what the exact quote is but he was like
yeah I told the studio this is a rough business
venture for everyone involved that's a thick ass
runtime man yeah and so the movie has to justify
you know people wanting to keep going back to
re-experience that and then of course the other
main topic is streaming is way more prevalent than
ever you know especially during the pandemic time
we've become more selective now of like me was
already a thing but it's more of a thing now
like do I really need to go to the theaters to
watch this yeah and that has certainly affected
the big spectacle movies and certainly with movies
that don't have maybe as appealing of a story from
the outside looking in you know people would be
including to wait for streaming and I feel like
Avatar does have ground to make up in that there
is a camp of people who are probably not that
enthused and are going to automatically decide
to wait this movie has a chance of having great
legs for for many many weeks to come even though
the first one made close to three billion dollars
again re-releases combined made it like to 2
billion uh on it's a traditional release I believe
because yeah I became like the number one highest
grossing movie of all time so I'm rooting for the
film I'm like I'm rooted for the film but even
from this spectator set I'm like that's a water
to try to just go all right I didn't lose any
money and two having that experience like we had
with Justice League the first time around where
you're like this movie is making a lot of money
and it's still tanky like I don't I'm so nervous
to see this like make a billion point five and
people go man Avatar really underperformed yeah
you could feed a whole nation with the gross
it's failing at the box office still do you
guys think it'll regenerate like a serious
profit do you think it'll come close to matching
The Profit that the first movie ended up making
because yeah that's a tall order right there man
and there's a lot of things working against it so
to think about oh wow this movie might actually be
getting all those reports that I see about wakanda
forever and Black Adam just on the biggest
possible imaginable scale I don't want it to
though no I want them to win I don't want them to
as much as the eye of dogged Avatar in the past I
really hope they succeed because this is exciting
I think they can do it I'll be more than happy if
they do guys leave your thoughts down below be
sure to subscribe leave a like click that Bell
and keep a lookout for when we do have our Avatar
the way of water review because uh they're gonna
need that they better hope we like it I hope we
like it because we we are influencers right and
we will influence you into not seeing it
if we don't like it Think Like Us [Music]